welcome to this video playing Mike puff
puff if you place I don't know if he is
playing I don't know come on you're
still sad about the the football match
France Germany no I'm not quite sure
when this video will be released
probably the world cup is already over
and we know if Germany managed to win it
finally after 24 years no the time of
recording this is not yet clear okay we
have the Rue La Paz exchange variation
my specialty with Bishop e7 what he's
taking e5 it seems that he actually does
know the line there should be six you
can also go g6 it's some and so it's a
funny funny sideline and I came this is
a bit uncommon Knight f3 mostly because
um I now normally get the Queen's traded
queen a five I think so
yeah and here we have a case where I
managed to trade the e pawns without any
particular problem and I have kept the
two bishops here the only slight issue
is that i'm somewhat behind the
development and my coordination could be
could be better how to develop him peace
coming to e5 is also slightly
problematic and then don't want to give
up one of the bishops of course this is
some let's say my trump card maybe I can
go Mookie aid that's a bit artificial
rookie 89 f 6 then move the bishop it's
very that's very ambitious I could have
played some easy stuff but let's see we
are still Knight f6 simply or not oh I
wonder what what the ideas is there
something direct orders you just want to
get into this terrible endgame maybe he
wants okay two bishops against two
nights it's not much a really bad idea
just rupee eight no that's no problem
with that my king is slightly slightly
deactivated here 28 but still I only
need to check that he's not able to
exchange one of the bishops which
instantly would lead to a quality of
course
yeah I need to retreat them momentarily
and then push the Knights back with f5
f5 is clear so that's really
questionable how does he protect the
poor now now if a g4 was a bad move he
has no way to protect the pond quite
quite directly i take it and it cannot
cover it okay just be six right it's
really not a big threat 95 but why not
be six asking black what the nida sale
exactly doing on a3 and a4 yeah I'll
take this next move
and the bishops and the pawn that's a
bit much so how do how to continue I can
of course use my Mac pawns okay can you
go King if I if this would be would be a
bit of an annoyance should I play Bishop
d6 to make sure this is not happening
maybe it's not nice to give up the porn
either the bishop but okay it's still
excellent for black
g5 Jack go d 5 yeah why not Knight f6
King has this is a journey with no
return tickets I ya know this is going
to I can go to h5 ok that's true um how
to do it now maybe just grab more space
King king over I guess King to e5
yeah this is one way to do it going to
d1 at the end take here Shannon we
should be one nice pawns our own light
squares check go here six to eight it's
probably the easiest Nigel six kinky 698
so then you can pick up a six but I can
I can grab the whole queenside check
now night b8 King c7 it's real interrupt
resigns yeah this is a very typical case
well um wrong continuation early led to
a very a prospectus game here here white
absolutely must play d3 to fight for an
advantage the ideas that after Knight f6
yoga Knight f3 and Jessia is the way it
is continued here white can can try to
play on for something it's pretty okay
for black but it's it's nothing nothing
special yeah here I get the poem back
and yeah I can take C 2 but i wasn't
interested in that I was just thinking
okay get the Greens off and here
blackest is very comfortable it's just a
matter how to play it precisely rookie a
dozen ambitious move it wants to play
Knight f6 so that rookie 7 is not not
possible so it's a preparation move and
I'm not sure about this move Bishop g5
if you never want to take on f6 really
and he did that he took here which is
quite remarkable just giving me the
total Bishop parent and here yeah the
easiest is to just trade of rooks which
I said here of course Black is just much
more comfortable this is not helping him
much but the real problem was g4 after
that he's losing I mean if you play a
play decently from here you have chances
to set up a fortress yeah or something
like that it's pure pure passive defense
but still possible maybe f4i moves like
that after g4 f5 he's just giving up a
pond and end its losing basically okay
thanks for watching